[Musik]
der dänische
investigativjournalist nils fastrup hat
einen Tipp bekommen
[Musik]
ein russisches spionageschiff
angeblich kartografiertes gerade die
dänische Infrastruktur
eine Quelle
hat
uns Mitglieder
ich glaube sie beobachten uns zwei
Männer starren uns an
da ist ein Typ mit
mit
einem gewehrt
im
Frühjahr 22 beginnt eine Gruppe
skandinavischer
investigativjournalisten über russische
Spionagetätigkeiten in Nord- und Ostsee
zu recherchieren
mitten in den Nachforschungen erfahren
Sie von den Anschlägen auf die Nord
Stream Pipelines dein Video von
dänischen Verteidigungsministerium
[Musik]
verdammt
Nils fastrup macht sich auf Spurensuche
ja Papa ich bin auf dem Weg zu einer
britischen Quelle ein hahnung er hat
neue Informationen über nord-street
die Quelle ein ehemaliger Geheimdienst
Offizier der Royal Navy wir nennen ihn
James seit dem Ruhestand beobachtet er
den russischen Schiffsverkehr
vor allem das meeresforschungsschiff
sibyakov weckte mein Interesse
es hat eine Kabeltrasse und ist ein
bekanntes u-boot-begleitschiff
und das wichtigste es ist zur
unterwasserbeobachtung fähig er hat
entdeckt einige Wochen vorher verlässt
das Schiff seinen Kurs und fährt ein
verdächtiges Manöver
sie befand sich südöstlich von
Karlskrona und etwa 45 seemeil
nordöstlich der Insel Bornholm also in
der Nähe des späteren nördlichen
explosionsortes
abends drehte sie wieder nach Osten ab
ein sehr merkwürdiger Kurs
am 14 und 15 Juni fuhr sie zwei
Schleifen
meine Hypothese sie führte eine langsame
Operation über der Nord Stream Pipeline
durch
ob wirklich Russland mit den Anschlägen
auf die Nord Stream Pipelines zu tun hat
ist unklar ungewöhnlich aber auch die
Route der wladimirski der Nils fast trop
sich genährt hat auch diese hat der
ex-geheimdienst offiziert James verfolgt
sie fährt in den Skagerrak und dann
durch die Nordsee
Schottland
steht ein großer Windpark den sie sehr
langsam passiert
dann verlässt sie das Gebiet Richtung
Süden
kann ist ein weiterer Windpark
dann fährt sie die Ostküste
Großbritanniens entlang
ich habe nachgeschaut was sie dort macht
und siehe da östlich von London stehen
drei oder vier Windparks
dann passiert sie diesen Punkt vor der
Nordküste der Niederlande dort steht ein
weiteres großes Windparkprojekt
insgesamt hat sie sieben Windparks auf
dieser Mission besucht
ativ vor der dänischen Küste Wind
Energie macht bereits 15 Prozent der
europäischen Energieversorgung aus
wir nehmen Kurs von gestern aus auf den
Windpark von nüstet
wir haben freie Fahrt um ihn herum und
durch ihn hindurch
zwischen den Windrädern hindurchfahren
man kann einfach reinfahren
von Windparks können leicht zerstört
werden
Tag das Offensichtliche Ziel wäre die
Kartierung der Stromkabel unter den
Windparks sie sind sehr widerstandsfähig
gebaut haben aber auch viele
Schwachstellen für Angriffe
an bestimmten Kabelsträngen könnte eine
Bombe den ganzen Windpark lahmlegen
insbesondere an Transformator und dem
Kabel jeder Turbine zum Transformator
zur Küste
zeigen
zur Zeit ist die europäische maritime
Infrastruktur ungeschützt
der Kreml bestreitet öffentlich Russland
plane Sabotage Akte gegen europäische
Energieanlagen